hey you guys want to do some color
grading yes well you're in luck because
this video is about color grading I'm
about to teach you some really awesome
tips and tricks and fundamentals all the
good things you need to know to get
really cinematic good looking color
grades in your footage okay let's get
started
not on the computer follow me shot a
video right you got a timeline you have
a whole bunch of little clips and maybe
it looks something like this right this
is maybe a clip of a person the house in
a car and they're each different types
of shots there are two different stages
it's correction and there's grading and
they go hand in hand here's what you
should think about organizing your stuff
like we're we're cooking your in it
doesn't matter they all generally offer
the same flow first things first is you
want to think of your grade as being
something that's going to be applied
over the top like a layer over
everything at least for the scene that's
going to have that great apply and your
correction then be applied on the clip
by clip level so the way I like to work
is I like to apply my grade first and I
go to a shot swell exposed and kind of
dial in my look and start scrubbing
around and see how well that look is
holding up to the other shots now
there's a shot this little too dark a
shot that has a long kind of tint it's
not a big deal I just do my individual
correction for that and basically at the
end of the day I could wipe out my whole
grade and my corrections still gonna
basically leave all these shots balanced
with each other which is great then I
can apply a whole new grade later on and
it still works it's still consistent
across everything so let me go show you
guys how do some actual cool grades I
just got a call from Derek and
apparently his tire exploded on 4th
Street he's gonna send a pin right now
and we're gonna go pick him up Derek got
off a decently hard exit in East LA I
don't think he knows where he is the
real reason why I wanted to go do this
is so that I can Joyride Sam's car don't
tell them that it's like a racing model
it's like super easy to drive this thing
compared to my truck
this baby's ready to roll you ready did
I good when you work with corridor
digital better be ready to die so
apparently we have some fans at LG
because they actually sent us a 4k LG
monitor this is actually the UD 88
I've never actually used a 4k monitor
before it's really nice I'm not gonna
lie you guys are looking for a nice
monitor to color great on having worked
this monitor for the past week it gets
my endorsement here I have just a
collection of random shots that we got
with this little black magic micro
camera the Blackmagic camera shoots a
flat profile the flat profile is often
referred to as a logarithmic profile has
to do with how the image is scaling the
luma values from black to white at the
end of the day here's all you really
need to know when you're shooting with a
flat picture or a log picture you're
preserving as much of your dynamic range
as possible because at the end of the
day if you're already shooting in that
contrast the image you can't go and fix
things like under exposure or over
exposure because all your shadows will
have already been crushed down to black
and there's no detail there to bring
anything back in that gives you the room
later on to fix things adjust things
manipulate things as you see fit but
downside is that your footage looks like
junk when it comes out of the camera and
that's where color grading comes in all
right so let's make something that looks
good right let's take this really flat
footage and make it look nice so I like
to start the shot that is a human being
in it for example here we have Sam and
one of the reasons I like to start with
a shot with a human being because we
have skin tones skin tones are very
important when you're color grading no
matter where you go with your footage
whether it goes cool or warm or really
contrast E or whatever at the end of the
day you want the skin to stay slightly
reddish orange it doesn't matter what
race you are your skin is slightly
reddish orange may be brighter or darker
but all skins are the same hue
across-the-board step one we're going to
add some contrast a lot of programs have
these things called color wheels so they
represent your lows so middles and highs
in terms of your brightness so I'll take
my lows and I'll pull those down a
little bit and I'll take my highs and
I'll bump those up a little bit you
usually have something called a scope in
your program on this case I'm looking at
a waveform which kind of shows me where
my value is sit so I can see where my
highs are and I can raise those up and
down until for example they're touching
the top of the graph which means they're
being blown out to white or they can
kind of sit a little bit below same
thing with your lows you can raise
goes up and down you can see where they
are and generally speaking the bottom of
the graph is black so once your values
are hitting that they're getting crushed
to full black there's also a contrast
dial it can bump that up a little bit
more is this it he has a silver BMW and
he's stuck in a bad neighborhood it
boils keep an eye on Karen he's on
fourth
when I talked to him on the phone it
sounded like he had gotten off and he
was on the corner of 4th and pecan but I
couldn't hear him very clearly and then
so I asked him to send me a pin he never
did see him I don't think so
hey dude where are you I'm on 4th I'll
meet you there I'm gonna I mean Sam's
blue car I'm I'm on but now the other
thing is if you're shooting with flat
footage as it tends to be very D
saturated D saturated means it doesn't
have a lot of color in it so we want to
raise the amount of color in the footage
so I can turn on my saturation just a
little bit here yeah it's starting to
look nice it's a little warm I could
color correct the shot just a little bit
by tinting for example my whites towards
blue just a little bit there we go looks
a little bit more natural before after
before after now I'm in clip view in
DaVinci which will only apply a color
grade to a specific clip actually gonna
flip over to Timeline view which will
apply it to everything now I can hop
around and see how my grade looks in
other shots for the shot Jake sitting at
his desk before after looks pretty good
let's push it just a little bit further
I'm going to do a simple stylization
first I'm a classic cinema look is to
have slightly blue cool shadows so I'm
going to take my shadows I'm just going
to pull this down to have a blue
direction okay everything looks blue and
cowlicks crappy now we're going to go in
the opposite direction with our
mid-tones we're going to try to get
those skin tones fact that orangish red
hue there we go and now if I want to
think of my highlights I can maybe make
them a little bit cooler live a little
warmer I can make the GoGreen with them
really comes down to the style you're
seen it's gonna go a little cool here
now because both my shadows and my
highlights are going cool my skin is
getting a little faded again so I'm
going to push it even a little further
towards orange and now I have a little
more of an interesting shot where
there's a little more of like a color
cast in my darks let's go even further
let's get really extreme it's important
to know a little bit your color theory
as you work on this kind of stuff if you
look at these color wheels they
basically show you colors that are
opposite each other if you take those
two colors and combine them they cancel
each other out so that's why for example
I'm taking my mid-tones and pushing them
in the opposite direction of my shadows
because they cancel each other out and
what you end up getting is you get
really dark parts of the shadows or my
mid-tones aren't touching or influencing
they stay kind of blue the upper parts
of my mid-tones or my shadows aren't
really influencing things those get a
little more normal a little more warm in
the middle where they meet they're kind
of transitioning through that's where
you get some interesting color gradients
that's how you can utilize his color
wheels kind of inform yourself what's
happening that's what learning a little
bit of color theory will help you with
pick on yeah it's right up here and so
we must have passed him
I go where are you guys I'm on the
corner I go the corner of what he goes
ah just on the corner man I'm in LA on a
corner right there he is I see him Derek
hey what's up dude look at this I think
that this is broken
I don't know if I can drive you think
that's legal drive like that tape it
well you see what you got there is a
classic blowout when Walmart has a big
sale it happens when Derrick gets off
the freeway it happens when kanye west
spends too long snorting cocaine at a
strip club
classic blowout either way you end up on
the side of a curb in the middle of Los
Angeles ah well thanks guys appreciate
the pickup my great is on top of the
whole thing I'm just going through now
shot by shot and correcting each shot to
work under that grade brightness the
same color space the same tonality
evening out all my footage by having a
great over everything and then just
doing my individual Corrections and now
I can go back to my grade at the end of
the day let's say I'm talking to my
friend he's like dude you should really
think about making the shadows green not
blue oh you're so right I could just
bagful and now my shadows are green and
it applies to the entire piece and
because everything's been corrected
together under that grade everything
still looks good I don't have to go
through shot by shot by shot and refix
everything whether you're working in
Premiere you're working da Vinci working
in anything else the whole layer method
of doing your correction shot by shot by
shot but in your grade over everything
is a great way to organize things I was
working to Vinci da Vinci's free
straight-up free so you guys can
download it and mess around of color
grading in there if you guys are using
Premiere you'll have access to lumetri
and it's a quick and easy way to kind of
replicate all of stuff I hope you guys
enjoyed the little color grade tutorial
session it's a very deep world there of
options and abilities I mean its color
people can working with colors for
hundreds of years there's no real right
or wrong way to do it there's just tips
and techniques that look good that you
can kind of think about LG thanks to the
nice monitors it makes my color grades
look really good mmm